are you out of your mind here's the
debate
you're upset
okay we're officially live episode
number 161
with the one and only richard werner if
you don't know who he is
let me give you a little bit of
background you're going to want to
listen to today's podcast and but you
know sometimes you bring a guest in
where
uh maybe you're not in the world where
you follow a name like that you're like
yeah i've never heard of him before
in 2003 the world economic forum davos
selected him as a global leader for
tomorrow
uh he in 1995 uh proposed a
program or you know he labeled you know
these two words it was called
quantitative easing and it was written
in nikkei which is the dao of japan but
also the largest financial newspaper in
the world with three million
subscribers talking about the way to
address some of the challenges that's
been faces possibly quantitative easing
which later on in 2008
we ended up announcing november of 2008
in u.s that we're going to do
quantitative easing and by 2009 we ended
up i don't know 1.25 trillion dollars of
mortgage-backed securities
200 billion dollars in agency debt and
300 billion dollars and long-term
treasury that was bought by the
government uh to help us bail out and
some say that was a good idea some say
it was a bad idea today we're going to
talk about him if he was happy about the
proposing that quantitative easing that
u.s took and then
i asked him off camera and uh you know
he did a documentary
a few years ago in regards to japan's
economy and and what happened in japan
and some of the statistics that some of
you that are listening to this the
reason why this is we're having a lot of
conversations right now with marky crash
there are those that say it's not going
to happen it's just fear-mongering
there's gaslighting you know you guys
are people are just talking about that
stuff because it's a business model fine
and there are those who are sincerely
concerned
uh japan from 1990 to 2003
uh over 200 000 companies filed
bankruptcies the market dropped 80 and i
want to know why and i want to know if
there's any similarities with what
happened then to what happened now so
all the way from uk richard werner thank
you so much for being a guest on the
podcast today thank you very much thanks
for having me it's a great pleasure yes
so for some people that don't know your
background if you don't mind taking a
moment and just kind of tell them some
of the things you worked on so they know
your background
all right well um i'm originally from
germany did my first degree in the uk at
the london school of economics in
economics
doctorate from the university of oxford
in economics
um but i wanted to
find out how the world really works
there was a bit um
disillusioned with the academic
economics teacher at university very
abstract mathematical and
not really very much connected to
reality
so um i took the chance
uh while being at oxford uh in the early
stages of my my postgraduate and
doctoral work to go to japan
and was there initially as an intern for
deutsche bank and then
as
actually a government scholar at the
university of tokyo
and also doing a part-time job at the
nomura research institute
learning japanese um doing a bit of
japanese archery and also
trying to to speak to as many people as
possible to find out what's really
happening and what are the mechanics and
what's going on and then this year again
what's the year you know um that was in
1990 okay
the following year i became the first
shimamura fellow at the japan
development bank now called the
development bank of japan um government
bank um
shimomura actually is an interesting
character if we have time we can return
to him
but he's very little known and and they
certainly also didn't tell me much about
him at the time
anyway and so i spent well in total in
the end i ended up in japan for 12 years
and
developing in the early stages
my first paper that was out in 1991
um
the the big puzzle then was
um where's all this japanese money
coming from because in the 1980s
japanese money had been flooding the
world buying up everything in in in the
us uh why
uh
in europe
you know
plants uh factories being
um
[Music]
established all over the the world
japanese money yes manhattan pebbles
beach golf course uh the um
uh
yeah world trade what was it in in
manhattan the um
um one of the big buildings i mean is it
the land under rockefeller center
exactly
i remember that um all sorts and so um
the intriguing thing was
where did all this money come from
because it was actually more money
than
any economic theory
would uh would tell you should be coming
from japan and also they weren't really
earning much money on it so it was
against the economic incentives
and nobody could explain it and they had
you know these standard models of
capital flows didn't work
and so i i wanted to solve that puzzle
and in the
at the peak in 1987
japanese long-term capital outflows were
i mean it was a world record amount
unprecedented
it was
twice as large as the already world
record current account surplus
where was the money coming from and so i
researched that and the answer to that
gave me an answer to many other things
including enabled me to uh to warn later
in 1991 that
japanese banks which at that time were
the biggest in the world and the top 20
banks in the world were all japanese
by assets you know um top 20 banks in
the world were all japanese this is 1919
1991 exactly this is right at the end of
reagan's two terms yes and at the end of
this
you know japanese um economic boom
and also japanese money flooding the
world and people were talking about the
japanese century now beginning uh which
didn't quite happen but it took it took
people a long time to realize this but
my so at that time when
japanese banks were top and the economy
is growing at seven percent there was a
bit of a
you know glitch in the stock market
stock prices had fallen a bit 20 percent
25 percent 30 percent a bit more
but then the bank of japan in 91 was
lowering interest rates and most people
thought well that's the signal now buy
japanese stocks
that's when i put out my first paper my
conclusion was don't buy japanese stocks
japanese banks
are likely to go bankrupt and japan is
likely to move into the biggest
recession since the great depression
um and you should
short japanese stocks which you also did
at the time and they knew it which is
why they were buying hard assets all
around the world like real estate
and the answer to the question where did
they get the money from
is actually they just created it out of
nothing
because i uncovered at the time
the the process that actually drives um
all of our economies
and and of course you know i found out
in japanese case
um you know economic growth is something
you get
only when there's also money creation
going on but money creation for
gdp you know your economy um gross
domestic product that's how we measure
the economy so money creation that is
used for investment and so on in the
economy
for transactions fueling gdp
if that increases you get more gdp more
nominal gdp
of course if money creation goes into
asset purchases you get an acid bubble
so i discovered this mechanism and what
is the money creation most people think
it's it's the government that creates
the money supply actually much later i
did a survey with with my students in
frankfurt we asked over a thousand
people
sort of you know in central frankfurt
probably above average educational
levels and the question was who do you
think
creates and allocates the majority of
the money supply
and then give them some options and of
course being in frankfurt includes the
bundesbank the german central bank
the ecb at that time as well also in
frankfurt
but the german government all sorts of
options
and most i mean 84 responded well it's
either the government or the central
bank you know yeah one of those ecb bond
you know on this bank
that's what 84 thought and of course
that's wrong because the reality is
governments don't create any money these
days
that task has been
given away delegated that power has been
given away
um
by the people from the people to
somebody else um
central banks well they do create some
money
essentially the paper money the cash but
that's usually around only two to three
percent of the money supply so the
question is who creates the 97 of the
money supply that is fueling the economy
asset markets
um
you know if you do it correctly create
economic growth
well
it comes from the banks
banks create money when a bank gives out
a loan
it's not using existing money it's not
using deposits
it is actually newly creating money out
of nothing so bank loan is always new
money creation new purchasing power is
given to the borrower and added to the
money supply
and this is new personnel that didn't
exist before
now once you understand that then you
start to see how things fit together
don't they have certain limitations on
how much money they can lend based on
reserves yeah lever limits right right
there's a it seems 40 cents on a dollar
i i want to say insurance is 40 cents i
don't know
banks obviously can leverage a ton more
where they're you know the numbers the
expectation isn't as high
but they have a certain number they have
to go off right well it does depend and
and really this um this point that
you're raising is an important one you
know what's what's the story with these
bank reserves and reserve requirements
and isn't that a way for the central
bank to actually control it so
ultimately the central bank is
is really fine-tuning the money supply
well it doesn't quite work that way
and you can see this immediately when
you look at many countries such as the
uk
but also
australia new zealand
in fact many countries nowadays
have zero reserve requirements so then
you realize well okay the reserve
requires can't be the key story the zero
um
what we many countries have zero reserve
requirements yes any of these countries
are any of the bigger you know countries
in the world yep such as the uk uk zero
it's been zero for for decades so who
holds them accountable on the amount of
money they can lend yes well there is
actually another variable that's been
used
to influence banks and actually it's a
good point perhaps let's let's go
quickly through this
um i mean i'm professor of banking and i
was astonished to find that the experts
the textbooks um
the researchers weren't even sure how
banks actually work
and i found that there's three theories
of banking three theories of how banking
works and when we when we talk about
banking the key function that
distinguishes banks from others is
actually in their lending operations
and the key question there is where does
the money come from
actually one of my books where does
money come from you know it has this
title and so where does the money come
from that the banks
use when they give out a loan and that's
where the three theories of banking are
different from each other
now the the currently dominant one the
mainstream theory that is pushed in the
textbooks is oh banks
they're not very special you know
nothing to see here move on
there's nothing special about banks
they're just financially intermediaries
that's the financial intermediation
theory of banking
and they say banks lend out their
deposits right savings on the left loans
on the right and just in the middle yes
yes exactly and with that theory what
regulatory tool to control banks is
being used it's actually
capital requirements
um so since the basel accords in the
late 1980s it's been capital that's been
used mainly to
get a handle on what banks are doing and
the idea is that this will control and
restrict banks activities so we won't
have banking crises well has that worked
have we had banking crises since 1988
tons of them in fact dozens and dozens
if you look at the whole globe we had
um for some that don't know you were
with bear stearns for 14 years or 13
years right absolutely not that long but
i was at best earns asset management
senior managing director senior
portfolio manager i was also at jardine
fleming securities uh before in in japan
um as chief economist
the reason why i say that is to say
you're not just a professor because
sometimes you know professor is seen as
you know the intellect who just stands
up and talks and has never been in the
operating room that's doing the work
you've been
you know in both places yeah precisely
and in fact that's the whole point
because i realized these
um academics and and their theories are
mostly wrong
and we have to hold them to account and
we have to actually ask the question
what is reality how do things really
work so this theory that banks are just
intermediaries um they gather deposits
they lend out those deposits and we can
use therefore bank capital requirements
as a tool to keep the banks under
control
is plain wrong
we'll come to that there's a second
theory that's an older one that was
dominant from the 1930s to 1960s
and that is the fractional reserve
theory of banking now a lot of people
have heard this and i'm sure you have
because you mentioned the reserve
requirement and that's important in this
theory this theory says when a bank
lends money it needs to have some excess
reserves and it will be using those for
the new lending
and you know if if banks are all loaned
up with their reserve requirements they
can't give out new loans so they first
need to have some excess reserves that
could be from the central bank helping
them but that's the mechanics
now um that theory was dominant until
the 60s
and he did have an interesting feature
that got a lot of people interested in
this namely the so-called money
multiplier so it says that each
individual bank is just an intermediary
they gather deposits and lend them out
but in aggregate as banks interact
using this reserve requirement somehow
there is
leverage money creation happening and
therefore there's a money multiplier
there now that theory
actually
gave away the fact that there's
something strange happening and banks
create money and that was too much for
the powers that be to handle that's why
since the 60s they've pushed the
financial intermediate theory which says
oh there's nothing to see here at all
money creation oh no no it's not
happening
but there's a third theory that's the
oldest
and as it turns out the one that's
really true
um it's the one that sounds initially
slightly crazy but it was dominant until
the 1920s 1930s and that one said that
oh no banks are not intermediaries
they're not financial intermediaries
banks are creators of money
if you get a loan this is new money
creation and the bank
will will create new money into
existence that's the one that that
you're getting when you take out a loan
we could talk about how this actually
works and how they make it work
um but there's these three theories and
that one has been suppressed quite a lot
but you also find actually for each of
the three theories you find famous
economists supporting them
um keynes
john maynard keynes the famous 20th
century british economist
he actually supported
all of them in sequence
now he moved first he supported when he
was young the the credit creation theory
the banks created money out of nothing
later he moved on to the
um
fractional reserve theory and then even
the financial intimidation theory so he
moved away from the truth as it turns
out now i thought well this is
ridiculous we've got three theories
which one is true what's the scientific
thing to do let's look at the data let's
look at the facts let's do an empirical
test
so i conducted the first empirical tests
of
banking and how do banks actually work
and which of the theories of banking is
true uh which was the first empirical
test in the 5000 year history of banking
if you want
you can actually get this online if you
just google
one paper is entitled
can banks individually create money out
of nothing
can banks create money out of nothing
individually creating money
yes because in aggregate you see that
would be one of the theories but
actually individually
out of nothing that's the most radical
one that's the the credit creation one
that's it that's it exactly
um and secondly um the other paper is
called lost century in economics
and that one also has the three theories
of banking has another empirical test
these are two different types of
empirical tests and that's the one and
the conclusion is that
the current dominant theory that banks
are just financial intermediaries that
one is rejected
by the empirical evidence and also the
theory that
the fractional reserve
argument money multiplier holds is also
rejected
and the only one that is supported by
the empirical evidence is the credit
creation theories banks create money out
of nothing so it's now an empirically
established
fact
um
but who again who holds them accountable
though
so banks create money out of nothing
who holds them accountable everybody has
somebody to be held accountable to who
are they being held accountable to
that's right now that's where it gets
interesting and we can go back to japan
now um because once you realize well wow
this is how powerful banks
are because that you see their their
decision who gets new money who gets a
loan you know
means somebody gets new money that
didn't exist before and that will have
an impact on the economy and the
question is also what is it going to be
used for which types of transactions is
it going to be for consumption if and
banks usually copy each other so if the
banks lend a lot for consumption then
you will get inflation that's something
we need to talk about later because
that's what we're currently getting and
you know i've been warning since 2020
that we'll get significant inflation now
unlike
uh for example after the 2008 crisis and
and the bailout measures then it's very
different now this is inflationary um if
banks create money and it's used for
for purchases of ownership rights such
as property real estate or financial
assets you know all these loans to to do
financial
deals
that will push up asset prices because
it's like creating new money say let's
let's look at real estate property um if
banks give out a lot of
property loans and real estate loans
it's like printing money and pumping it
into the property market what's going to
happen right you don't need to be a
rocket scientist no okay they're pushing
up asset prices um and the third
possibility and there's only these three
really
the third possibility that's the
redeeming feature of banks if banks
give a loan that means they create
credit they create money and give it to
a firm
for productive business investment
that implements new ideas new
technologies increases productivity
that gives us economic growth without
inflation that gives us job creation
that gives us uh really what we want
without all the negatives you know
without asset price inflation without
consumer price inflation without banking
crises
whereas the other type lending for
consumption and also
bank credit for
asset purchases you know get the acid
bubble and after the asset bubble you
will always get and this is also what
happened in japan of course most
dramatically
you'll get a bust asset bubble
and then a bus banking system
and when the banks shut down they don't
lend at all then you also don't get
economic growth because for growth we
need new money creation in the system
um and so i i formalized that and tested
that in the early 90s on japan
as the as the general quantity theory or
the quantity theory of credit of
disaggregated credit where you you
recognize money creation money is
actually credit bank credit that's how
you measure the money supply correctly
you know central banks will always tell
you money supply we don't know what the
money supply is we don't really know the
textbooks also say that we don't know
what money is come on gotta be kidding
they just didn't want to tell you right
the true story it is bank credit we can
measure it it can be identified quite
clearly
um and the question is what is this
being used for
and so if it's used for productive
purposes that's when you get um job
creation growth no inflation
um you get all the positive things and
not the negative things asset bubbles
banking crises increased inequality and
inflation all that these things that's
when it's used for unproductive and
therefore unsustainable purposes and of
course there's something we should talk
about later as well
how can you have a banking system that
does
the right things and therefore supports
the economy best it's when you have
many many small banks local banks
community banks and that explains why
the u.s economy despite the various bad
government policies that have been going
on for a long time is still
fundamentally quite strong
the strength the secret of the strength
of the u.s economy and also actually the
german economy for the last 200 years
and also the japanese economy is because
they've got hundreds
if not thousands of small local
community banks banks that lend mainly
to small firms because the small firms
mostly engage in productive business
investment which creates jobs gives you
growth without the bad stuff without the
inflation without the acid bubbles uh
and banking crisis and so on but of
course you know
things can also go wrong particularly
again when the central banks intervene
so back to your question so who's who's
controlling these banks i mean how does
it work well
what i found out in japan it was a bit
of a detective story because first i
realized wow this okay this is this
house of cards is going to come down now
because they had all these
property loans real estate loans
in the 80s pushing up
land prices to stratospheric levels
in central tokyo
the
palace imperial palace garden
part of that is a public park and people
calculated okay that's a central tokyo
public park not that big but you know
okay
um what is the value if we use central
tokyo land prices and it turned out that
the value was the same as the entire all
the property real estate of the state of
california including los angeles san
francisco everything
which was crazy that was in 1989. that
was can you say that
i don't think the audience say that one
more time
so the asset prices were pushed up the
land price in japan were pushed up
through this mechanism yeah bank credit
for land purchases and property uh
transactions so much that at the peak
which is 1989
the um only a tiny speck of land in
central tokyo namely the imperial palace
garden they calculated you know the the
the size the the footage okay it's this
big what is the value using market
prices of central tokyo and it turned
out it was
the same value as the entire state of
california including all
uh real estate in india it's not a long
time ago this is 33 years ago exactly
correct and this how big is that place
the garden how big oh it's it's small i
mean it's not as big as a central park
in new york no it's not as big as
central park in new york yeah
like one-third
so so apart like some okay so so
while i'm watching the documentary and
you know we've read a lot on uh japan
and how a lot of people would send their
businessman from here to japan hey
the toyota way you know look at toyota
what they're doing and a great job japan
has done and they've done this and
they've done that in capitalism and
business
uh and and they have a very rich history
of business you know they they like
building companies that have been around
for a hundred plus years i think they're
the leading country in the world they
got 50 000 businesses that have been
around for 100 plus years and the oldest
company in the world
is based out of japan that's you know
that's something that we all know about
so we typically as entrepreneurs and
businessmen when you're really like oh
japan's got you know strong they're
long-term thinkers their business plan
is short-term business plan is 20 years
you know in america short-term business
plan is one year so we see we study how
they think right for business
but when i was looking at how they went
from a um democratic socialist model
they almost they had their own bernie
sanders or an aoc which you'll talk
about here in a minute
and then they went from
being nationalized to decentralized
then when it got decentralized it took
off and it did well then they got back
involved of wanting to be nationalized
to get the bigger banks to get bigger by
not doing smaller loans they got paid to
do the bigger loans you know let's not
give away
20 million dollars or 50 million dollars
why don't we do 200 million 100 million
dollars that's the bigger payday so
brokers started buying two three homes
because they had that kind of money
these young brokers that are coming up
and then all of a sudden boom they
realize this is not working out from
1990 to 2003 market drops 80 percent you
know 200 000 companies file bankruptcy
five million people lose their jobs the
leading cause of death
in japan and men ages 20 to 44 years old
with suicide
and that happens right my concern is
we in america have become oblivious to
these things that we can study to make
sure we don't repeat history that other
countries have made and the case studies
of these things are out there japan
being one of them so exactly for
somebody that's watching this and it's
fully uh open to open-minded to want to
hear your perspective
give us the similarities and concerns
you may have because later on i want to
get into inflation i want to get into
gold i want to get into crypto i want to
get into gas prices i want to get into
all of that stuff that i want to talk
about with the time that we have here
together but what similarities are you
seeing with the growth that japan
experienced and then the major fault
that they had
uh to what's going on right now in
america
yes well first of all
as exactly as you say we have these case
studies out there and as it turns out
the the number of very different cases
is actually quite small
because most of the time we see the
patterns repeat and repeat and repeat
and so there are a lot of similarities
so what what are the things that made
japan strong it is indeed as you said
the the companies um
of course also you know education and so
on but um
to have a large number of small firms
is is one of the
key ingredients of success and this is
true if you look at the whole world
two-thirds of employment is with small
firms small
enterprises even micro businesses they
account for the majority of employment
everywhere that's true in in the us in
germany japan
that's one thing
and actually it's an interesting
comparison if you look for example at
the uk today
they've been saying for the last well i
don't know five ten years constantly how
we have a problem our productivity is so
low why is productivity so low
and it's because um
it's not because they don't have
inventions lots of patent you know uh
registrations lots of ideas but somehow
the business sector is not very
productive and is also successful in
terms of exports
and then you've got this comparison very
close to the uk is germany and it's very
different productivity is very high
very successful
strong export exports until 2009 german
exports in absolute terms were larger
than chinese exports and of course
germany is tiny compared to china by any
measure
so how is that possible and if you study
that you find that a big percentage of
those exports are by small firms
family-owned businesses local small
firms
you know which are very important in the
german economy just like in the us
so how do they manage to be so
productive and the same story is true in
japan they they've managed to be very
very productive
and we can contrast this with the uk
where they're not very productive and
the difference is actually in the
banking sector
just to give you an example say here's
here's a small firm in germany
a new technology appears in their
industry
some new mechanisms some you know some
new technologies they didn't develop it
but they know it's out there if we don't
get it our firm is going to fall behind
we're going to lose market share we've
got to quickly upgrade now this costs
money
that's the main thing the small firms
are not the ones usually that have the
new patents you know they don't have to
they just need to implement the latest
technology but that costs money so in
germany where we have thousands of small
community banks
and historically always had very very
large number of community banks
thousands um
and and the principle is they only lend
locally so they know all their local
small firms very well
and have known them for years
um so the
you know the the owner of the small
company
would go to the bank and say look we've
got this new technology coming out in
our market we need to get this we need
money to upgrade otherwise we'll start
losing market share
the banker will already know the company
they know that you know they're reliable
maybe check this out a little bit and
they will quickly come to the conclusion
yeah that's true
they need the money we'll give it to
them and get a decision on the same day
maybe the next day
because that's their main business and
off they go they upgrade and they stay
highly competitive there is actually a
measure of such successful small firms i
mean there's a small firm definition
um employee number you know less than a
hundred or something and and by capital
and so on it's just using the
international small firm definition
a small firm
that is globally successful has top
market share like a champion in the
olympics gold silver bronze
so and they're known as hidden champions
they've got top number one two or three
market share in their niche
but they're small firms so we don't know
the name so like hidden you know they're
small films that fairly unknown by their
names they're not household brands right
so these hidden champions are these
globally successful small firms and
studies have been done okay which
country has most of these hidden
champions in the world
what do you think
which country has the most hidden
champions in the world so small firms
that are global leaders in their market
are you asking today yes today i mean it
has been true for for decades hasn't
changed for a long time
germany i don't know yes that's a
journey that's the one germany is number
one by far
number two and and the other one that
you think about is actually the us
because we know uh small firms also very
strong in the us and it is number two
but there's a huge gap so germany is
around 1 500 hidden champions the us has
around 350.
which is not bad but there's yeah
there's a big fight
exactly so why how's that possible is
because of the banking system germany
has so many small local
community banks
80 of all banks in germany are not for
profit local community banks cooperative
banks savings banks that lend only to
these uh small firms locally
that's how they're so strong and they
constantly can upgrade
and that's why job creation is is so
strong now japan has a similar system
um and the us historically has had a
similar system it's strongest in germany
because it remained unchanged in germany
for 200 years and none of these small
community banks has ever gone bust none
has ever needed a government bailout
and they they never changed the formula
they only lend locally once you start to
change the formula like in spain they
had them and then they said oh no they
should be able to lend across spain you
know you bust the system now in japan
and that's what you mentioned earlier
they also changed the formula
and
the big banks started to dominate
there's lots of bank mergers
the banking system getting more
concentrated
and of course this was part of the
movement in the 1980s as
banks were lending
too much money therefore creating too
much money and i studied this mechanism
and
because the question is still you know
how how you know yeah i still want to
know that exactly who's what i want to
know is
i want to know like specific
what happened in japan to have that
massive of a crisis that they had 80
percent in 13 years 200 thousand
companies file bankruptcy five million
what happened there and then what's him
i know where you're going with the small
banks right now but for the audience
that listening before we get to just
give the climate here's what they did
this is what took place here's what
happened they need to know that history
and then we can get into something
because i want them to ex exactly what
happened then exactly um
well i wanted to know that too
particularly once i predicted this huge
bust that japanese banks will now go
bankrupt and the whole japanese economy
is going to come to a halt i knew that
and from 1991 onwards i went back to
japan actually to the bank of japan i
was visiting researcher at the central
bank and my goal was to find out the
answer to that question how could it
ever
at that time most people didn't think
it's going to get that bad but i knew
this is going to be really bad so the
question is going to be so important how
do we ever get here who's responsible
what's the mechanism and of course the
mechanism is the
excess bank credit in the 80s when they
revved our bank lending for property for
real estate creating this huge asset
bubble property bubble
which is unsustainable this bank lending
therefore money creation just for asset
purchases it's a ponzi scheme like a
pyramid scheme snowball system
while banks keep creating credit for new
property purchases everything will go up
everyone is happy everyone makes money
even the tax man gets more revenues
everyone's happy but it's a it's a game
of musical chairs once the music stops
once banks stop creating credit for
these asset purchases then asset prices
don't rise anymore they start to fall
then the late coming speculators will
will already not have profits they'll go
bust you start to get non-performing
loans more and more and then the banks
will of course reduce bank credit
further until you get a full-blown
banking crisis because non-performing
assets
just need to reach 10
of banks portfolios and the banks are
bust because right it's all supported by
capital if you've got non-performing
loans there's a hole in the on the asset
side of your balance sheet where does
the money come from you've got to take
it from capital but bank capital is 10
or less so while in in an asset bubble
you push up asset prices by
100 200 300 400 percent from the peak
they only need to fall by 10 or a bit
more than that 15
and the banking system is based that's
why we have these recurring banking
crisis after the asset bubbles so the
question is then
why and how
was bank credit expanded so dramatically
for land purchase and property
transactions so i researched that and
the
the standard tools that are
researched by economists and researchers
in this interest rates and central bank
tools reserve requirements all sorts
they didn't yield any answers because
nothing unusual was happening that could
explain this dramatic development and i
kept asking people and reading more and
i started to hear that people say oh no
there's another tool oh but let's not
talk about it what do you mean another
tool oh no that's not official well i
don't care you know i i want to fight
even as oh no that's that's not an
official tool it's it's a sort of
it's a bit of a hidden tool all right
tell me more
in japan you have to if you really want
to find out what's happening
they will always tell you but you've got
to go for dinner and there has to be a
bit of saki
um and
because it's off the record after six
o'clock
they will tell you you're not supposed
to quote it and attribute it to them but
they will tell you the full story and
the full story is that um
of course um
the
there is there is a
secret monetary policy tool that has
been used by almost all central banks
but is not written about very much
because central banks don't want people
to look at it academic economists i mean
many of them you know get assignments
with central banks or are ex-central
bankers and they know what to write
about it what's good for your career and
what not to write about which is not
good for your career
and writing about this is considered
slightly dangerous for your career so
there's almost nothing at the time when
i researched this on this topic
um and then i did my again empirical
research i said okay i want to interview
bankers
that
personally as individuals
were in the late 1980s at a bank
and they were at the big banks and they
were dealing with the central bank
concerning this tool and i want to
interview central bankers
that were implementing this tool
vis-a-vis the banks and i want to hear
their stories and actually recorded them
i managed to do this because at the time
i was visiting research at the bank of
japan i had my name card bank of japan
and you go to the bank you know they
will
they will make time for you so i went to
the um
[Music]
to the banks and also to
the central bankers you know meeting
them for lunch and and so on and and
some um actually agreed yeah i can
record this that's fine
now
starting with the banks actually i
started by initially
asking people that were in the in the
branches of the banks
um loan officers just ordinary loan
officers i started with those
and they told me the story already um
well
the beginning of the story and so they
were saying well the 1980s was a crazy
time
i was giving loans left right and center
property loans real estate lending i
mean i was actually cold calling
companies and owners of of companies
or just um you know people who i thought
are wealthy enough i was cold calling
them and saying look we found a property
for you we've done the calculations
we'll give you the money please sign
here next year is going to go up by you
know 60 70 you're gonna make this much
money please sign here and
you'll get the money you get the
property that's how aggressively the
banks were pushing this is 80s yeah this
was the second half of the 80s and these
people would also say and and while we
did this we were very concerned because
i think we were creating an acid bubble
oh yeah you surely were well so my
question then was okay so why were you
doing it you realized this is kind of
risky well i was just doing as i was
told oh by who were you told well our
branch manager gave us loan increase
quotas for every quarter every three
month period we had to increase lending
by this much so we're just doing that
you know fulfilling our quota
so then i asked the branch managers i
wanted to get introductions to branch
managers
that in the late 80s were managers
heads of branches of banks and i
interviewed those
and
the story was the same they were saying
oh late 80s crazy time i did all this in
1992-93 so it was still fairly fresh you
know in people's minds and at the same
time people didn't realize the enormity
of what had happened yet dude they okay
so they don't know what's about to
happen exactly okay it hadn't really hit
the fan yet so
and i asked those um and they they would
say oh crazy time we were really i was
telling my my my loan officers to
increase lending dramatically property
we were really pushing up asset prices
this way it was kind of risky where i
think we're creating a bubble so why did
you do it well i was just doing as i was
told or by who
oh by the
the head office strategic planning
department gave us the the loan increase
plans so then i interviewed people at
the
the headquarters of the big banks in the
strategic planning department
and
what i heard there was oh late 1980s
crazy time we were pushing out those
loans left right and center we're really
pushing up asset prices by by telling
our loan officers you know to increase
lending this much we i think we're
creating a bubble it's kind of risky all
right okay so why did you do well we're
just doing what we're told by who like
the chairman of the bank
no no chairman in japan richard you must
understand they're just figureheads you
know no no they're not involved we do
you know we make the decisions for the
bank
so who told you to do this well the bank
of japan of course
the central bank
oh yes the central bank because we were
given
credit loan you know increase quotas
as part of the window guidance central
bank
informal extra legal monegy policy
control tool oh that's very interesting
actually some of the bankers already
told me oh yeah and that was decided
um at the central bank in the planning
depart in the um actually the banking
department where they deal with the
banks and head of the banking department
in the second half of the 80s was
somebody called mr fukui
he by the way this was in 92 when i
asked these questions he will be
governor of the bank of japan maybe in
10 years time or so
oh really are you sure yes he's one of
the princes what do you mean and they
were using the english word i mean these
were interviews conducted in japanese
but they would suddenly use the english
word prince
what do you mean he's a prince oh he's
been selected to be governor of the bank
of japan um 20 years ago
you know when he was in his in his 30s
of age he was would be selected to 30
years later become governor and there's
a very small number of people who are
selected this way
they're known inside the bank of japan
and in the financial circles as the
princess
because of this unusual very early
selection
so then i interviewed the central
bankers
and i managed to find some of those who
were
at the central bank in charge
um of meeting out those central bank
loan growth quotas to the banks
and and they told me of their jobs and
you know because at that time it wasn't
yet controversial they just freely told
me what they're doing well we were
telling the banks to increase their
lending it was kind of risky we're
really um asking them to increase their
property lending quite a lot
i guess we were creating an asset bubble
there weren't we
oh right so why were we doing it well i
was just doing what i was told by who by
the head of the banking department
i see and from 1986 uh to 1989 just when
this huge asset bubble and these huge
you know massive massively inflated
property prices were created
it was somebody called mr fukui
completely under the radar at the time
nobody in japan would have really
outside the financial banking sector
would have known him
but
one of the princes who
as i wrote in my book princes of the yen
would be future governor and the book
came out before he became governor which
a lot of people
a lot of people doubted that he will
become good but of course he did become
governor of the banker he was one of the
princes so the bank so the answer is the
bank of japan
using its
um very much hidden control tool of
directly directing bank credit because
that is the key variable and therefore
of course it does make sense you know if
you want to run the show you directly
tell the banks how much to lend
and they also
did this by industrial sector to some
extent whenever they wanted to
with this
window guidance
they forced the banks to create this
property bubble
which then had to completely blow up the
banking system and create a situation
where you then can have a
20-year recession if you want because
the banks will be paralyzed now the only
way out
and to to sort of re-liquefy the banks
and get the economy going again is
actually only if the central bank wants
to and the central bank can get out of
this very very easily
at no cost to the taxpayer um if it
wants to and the bank of japan chose not
to do this
that's detailed
in the book princes of the yen quantum
publishers.com is actually where you can
get it it's slightly hard to get but
there you'll get it very easily
and and cheapest
um
the
the reason why they wanted this of
course was the next question you know
what i mean what's the next question is
what is that reason why
were the central bank is doing this and
i found that so mr fukui
who was in charge of this window
guidance in the 80s and his boss
who was at the time deputy governor mr
mino
the earlier prince in the 1990s they
both moved up misdemeanor became
governor of the central bank
and mr mina became in the second half of
the 90s deputy governor you see and then
during the 90s they ensured that the
bank of japan kept the bank credit tight
and they did not solve this
um
emerging banking crisis but it was
clearly festering would get bigger and
bigger
and then in the 2000s again they didn't
really solve the problem
so we had and therefore banks didn't
create credit new credit for business
investment and therefore there was a
20-year recession it was these two guys
mino and fukui
and i studied this in detail what they
said and actually it's certainly not a
conspiracy because
they very clearly said in their speeches
um
in the 90s they said well we don't
really want a recovery now
because the recession is good for the
economy because
it it forces structural change on the
economy do you agree with that
no i i don't i think it's it's it's not
right to have an artificial recession no
no not artificial recession but how
about a a
okay so so you said let me take you back
a little bit i got that though so 1990
1991
you are curious at this point on what's
going on and you start investigating
you went all the way down from the
bankers all the way to the top of the
you know
the bank of japan and you kind of
realized fukui what's going on great
so
in 86 if you can for 30 seconds if you
can just kind of give us some
perspective from 86 to 89 how much was
value of real estate going up and what
kind of money were these guys making
just for us to kind of get a
visualization
well property prices were rising by
several hundred percent
per year uh in in um well in total so in
this in this three year three four years
you mean to tell me like a half a
million dollar property could end up
being a two million dollar property oh
yeah of course you're serious yes yeah
yeah yeah and okay so and this is
happening in specifically three years
yeah maybe four if you yeah at half a
year on both ends so so then then
how similar were interest rates like you
know how we dropped the rates down to
zero and we had 128 month economic
expansion oh my gosh what a great time
it was and then
you know what were they doing with
interest rates what did inflation look
like what did gas prices look like what
did unemployment look like was it like a
1.2 unemployment interest rates were
really low what what were the conditions
there
unemployment has always been low in
japan
that started to rise only from the
second half of the 1990s when the
recession started to get bad
and then in the 2000s you know we had we
hit
peak unemployment which but by
international standards is still low but
by japanese standards was the highest
ever
in earlier in the post-war era yes
um inflation
in the 80s was very low
as well
um because most money creation um was
going into asset prices and well so the
normal measure of inflation is consumer
prices consumer prices stayed fairly
uh constant fairly flat in fact there
was some deflation because the yen was
rising import prices were going down and
um and so you didn't see what was
happening
and then that's actually the reason why
as japan if we quickly moved to to
capital flows briefly japan was creating
all this money
uh via the asset markets
uh inflating asset prices and some of
that spilled over as capital outflows
that explains this flood of money and i
solved that puzzle you know this flood
of money from japan was this bankrupt
creation in asset markets now normally
you'd see that and you say well they're
just printing money and they're buying
foreign assets the yen should go down
but it's not a it's not an automatic
mechanism you know market players have
to understand this and realize oh
they're just printing the money
that's why we're going to sell the yen
and they start to sell the yen but this
didn't happen they saw oh consumer price
inflation zero or negative well the yen
they're obviously not printing money and
the yen should be strong and it stays
strong while they went around the world
buying up assets everywhere
um now you mentioned interest rates of
course that's it's an interesting
question always because any central bank
watcher
i mean in the mainstream will focus on
interest rates and central banks
themselves will always
try to get your attention um
focused on interest rates
and it's a bit like the magician on
stage when they're performing a trick
and of course they don't want you to see
what really does the trick
when they do that hand movement they
will distract your attention with the
other hand and say look here this is
happening maybe you have a little
diversion story
and that's what interest rates are
but it's such a huge diversion it's it's
worthwhile spending a few
moments on this because actually
famously there's so many different
schools in economics right different
schools of thought different economies
they all have different ideas they
always argue and squabble well
there's one
idea that all the different schools of
economic thought of the last 200 years
in english language economics
agree on
namely they all say if you lower rates
this is good for the economy growth will
go up if you raise interest rates this
will slow
the economy you can go back to david
ricardo classical economist alfred
marshall
neoclassical economics
keynes um certainly said that
monetarists
said that um
you know all sorts of uh neo-class new
classical economics um
neo-vixilian all the schools of thought
agree on this point and central bankers
for the last 30 years have been saying
this on a daily basis watch interest
rates because when we raise them it's
going to slow things if we lower them
it's going to stimulate
they say this constantly now
because this is repeated so many times
we all assume
quite reasonably that of course this has
been empirically tested and checked
hundreds of times maybe thousands of
times so we don't need to check this
right
well how many empirical studies exist
that demonstrate this relationship
five
zero wow there isn't one because
i did the first empirical check of this
it's very hard to publish this nobody
you know the economist don't want you to
see this but
um
what i found is it's not true
it's it's just not true there is no
empirical evidence for this
so the official so what we're doing
today in the states when we're
increasing rates to prevent from
inflation taking place
that makes zero sense to do it's not
gonna help it it's not gonna help if the
real cause of inflation which is not
interest rate is still in place and that
is money creation for
um unproductive purposes for consumption
if they keep doing that you can do that
at higher rates you can still push out
the
the credit creation in the banking
system you will get accelerating
inflation and in fact then you'll find
that the higher interest rates make
certain things more expensive mortgages
and whatever rents will start to move up
you know it's not gonna
end inflation if the credit creation
continues so i did i but i wanted to
show this because you can always have
scenarios where maybe you know you think
it could work or not so it's an
empirical question
and i did the first empirical test using
data on the us the uk germany and japan
for half a century
and it was open ended my my question was
simply what actually does the data tell
us is the relationship between interest
rates and we tried together with a
colleague
[Music]
econometrician
and we um we asked well
looking at three different types of
interest rates short rates
long-term 10-year government bond yields
and so on what is the relationship
between interest rates and economic
growth
the official story is is a negative
correlation lower rates higher growth
higher rates lower so negative inverse
relationship and causation supposed to
be from interest rates to growth there's
supposed to be some causation there what
we found
was
diametrically opposed to this on both in
both dimensions
the correlation
is actually positive
so higher rates and higher growth always
go hand in hand
lower rates and lower growth always go
hand in hand and the causation
statistical causation that you can test
for
runs from growth to interest rates
interest rates follow growth and
therefore they can't be the cause and
that tells you that can't be the the
best monarchy policy tool at all
that paper is published you can also
look it up that's called
it's also open source reconsidering
monetary policy
um the only journal that will publish
this fairly good journal still but um
was ecological economics it's in there
peer-reviewed journal
an empirical examination of the relation
between interest rates and gdp growth
we've got another paper coming out now
which looks at real growth industrial
production for 19 countries it's the
same conclusion so reality is interest
rates work differently and they're not
really the cause of what's happening so
but central banks love to talk about it
because that way they distract your
attention you focus on something that's
not key and they can then use that to to
make sure you don't really understand
yeah so what they're doing can i
challenge you please do so here's my
challenge i'd like you to for the next
questions i ask speak to us
as if people don't have an mba in
finance okay i want you to explain to
the average person that's listened to
this because i know sometimes
when i'm around
intellects or professors or teachers
they speak in that language and they
never know how to take the hat off of
that language right we had
who was a professor that we had that
flew out here that we had a on the
podcast a couple months ago extremely uh
uh smart
yeah berlinsky who i'm like can you
you know speak at the level of the
average person so i'm going to ask you
some questions but and i really yeah
yeah because i've watched i know how
much value there is in seeing this
and you know today in u.s okay
a lot of people were sitting there
historically we've been told when
a market crash happens or you know uh
too much of dollars being printed
gold prices go up nothing happened okay
so the gold crusaders were like oh
you're going to see what's going to
happen with gold and gold's going to go
to 5 000. okay all right sounds good why
if you look at the numbers with gold
anytime we've done this gold's gone up
it's time for the golden version we
printed forty percent american money we
printed a lot of we've never done this
before okay fine sounds good the crypto
community says well let me tell you
decentralized people have been asking
for decentralized we have it here right
and it's decentralized and the reality
of crypto is the fact that you know it's
different than everything else where
recently a paper came out if you can
zoom in here shown that bitcoin has been
trading with the stock market this year
so for the bitcoin community that's
pitching the fact that if the stock
market goes down bitcoin goes up or
whatever you know it's not the same i'm
sorry if you go a little lower to show
the data go a little lower if you show
the data right there go a little lower
to the second paragraph uh uh the data
right there shows of the 98 trading days
we've had so far bitcoin and s p 500
index have moved in the same exact
direction 73 of them while moving in the
opposite only
25 times so is there anything unique
about bitcoin compared to the stock
market or is bitcoin just now a digital
gold it's just another stock right so
okay so
we were thinking bitcoin if the market
was going to tank and we're going to
print money bitcoin's going to go to 100
000 200 000. nope it's at 29 000 today
okay well if you
if we increase interest rates and power
is going to increase interest rates that
means inflation's not going to go up and
it's going to stay at around four or
five percent nope it's at eight and a
half percent and we keep increasing
interest rates and
yeah but if we increase interest rates
you know real estate value is going to
take ahead and go but okay so
out of all the things that we're looking
at today
what are the main
data we ought to look at to say listen
we know the definition of a a recession
is two quarters in a row right it's the
numbers two quarters in a row when uh uh
covet happened and the market dropped
what fifty percent or forty percent in
the span of a month it came back up
that's not a recession that's a market
crash okay it's got to be two quarters
no fine we know that
what are some of the most concerning
data that you see in america today
that you're sitting there saying
things are not going to be good and if
it's something where you are saying
things are not going to be good how bad
are things going to be in the u.s
economy the next 12 24 36 60 months
okay well
there's a good comparison and that is
2008
and and then you know what happened
since 2020.
in 2008 we had essentially
a bubble collapsing that was more
similar to the japanese situation so the
banks were creating a lot of credit
um that was used for um property but
also various financial instruments so
you had your asset price surge
and once bank credit suddenly tightened
which happened very dramatically
september 2008 and the banking system
was simply shut down
then the acid bubble collapses and we
saw that
um
now at that time the federal reserve
acted very quickly in fact among
internationally among central banks it
was the one that reacted fastest and
also in the in the in the most proactive
way
um but the key thing is
bank credit shrank after that for you
know for a year bank credit just did not
expand and that's the biggest part
that's the money supply the federal
reserve stepped in it created a lot of
credit um on its own a lot of people
said that this would create inflation
now and the dollar would collapse
because look what the fed is doing
i was one of the few who were saying no
the the dollar is not going to collapse
and there's not going to be inflation
why because the fed is a small
cog and and the big wheel is the banking
system and they're shrinking so the
total money supply was actually not
expanding despite the the fed being
hyperactive now the fed did implement
one of my policy recommendations from
the true quantitative easing that i had
formulated in 1995
which is
and in my true def definition of true
quantitative easing of course is to
increase bank credit creation for the
real economy
how do you do that and there's some
steps um that the central bank can can
take to to do this
um and one is to help the banks restore
their the problems on their balance
sheet which they didn't do in japan for
a long time and i told them many times
in many publications and you know my
book princes of the end was a number one
bestseller in japan ahead of harry
potter for six weeks i was
on the japanese media
very regularly uh 2001 2002 2003
i was invited by parliament there was
advisory to various government
committees
but then never the central bank never
did this whereas the fed
um and you see at the time in the 1990s
when it's proposing this first from 95
onwards
um ben bernanke as academic was
participating in these debates about
japan
and he
as head of the fed did implement one of
my key recommendations and i was the
only central bank in the world that did
that in 2008 it was the fed namely
he
um took away these non-performing assets
from the banks from the big banks very
quickly
by simply and this was my recommendation
by simply having the central bank buy
them up
of course not at market value and
something you know 20 cents on a dollar
or higher much higher okay maybe not at
a high though why stressed assets right
so why though because the banks are
special they create the money supply and
you need them if you want an economic
recovery and while they're impaired you
could have a 20-year recession that's
what japan demonstrated right
um
and so
my recommendation was the central bank
should go and buy these non-performing
assets let's say at face value at 100
they're only worth 20 but the central
bank goes out and buys them
at 100. what happens the banks of course
are immediately restored i mean they're
more liquid than ever their balance
sheets are super strong they can now go
out and create credit do their normal
business and of course you should impose
some conditions you guys stop the bank
lending for the um asset purchases
give give out loans for productive
businesses they didn't they didn't do it
well that's what we could impose yeah
the fed didn't do that no um
but to help banks increase lending again
if you get rid of the non-farming as you
buy them up um that solves the problem
there's no tax money involved and
there's no cost to society you might say
well hang on there could be two types of
costs the central bank now has the
non-performing assets that's a cost
isn't it yeah but the central bank is a
special institution first of all it
doesn't have to mark the market
so you won't see this
also
um it you know central banks are always
profitable because they create the money
supply or they
at the core of the money supply process
let's say
um so i mean that if you want central
banks to be profitable i mean you should
arrest all the central banks for insider
trading you know of course the central
bank will always be profitable so it's
not a problem that the central bank is
purchased but actually they're not even
having any losses
why
if the central bank buys these
non-performing assets from the banks at
100 they're worth only 20. it is
possible to book this in the accounts of
the central bank as a loss of 80
but that wouldn't reflect reality and
accounts should reflect reality as much
as possible what is reality what is the
true gain
or loss that the central bank has it
doesn't have a loss it has a gain of 20.
it owns something worth 20.
and what did it pay
well the cost of funding is zero to the
central bank
so that's why you don't have to worry
about that it's a gain to the center
bank to buy anything but where's the
money from central bank coming from
you could say the central bank creates
it
now that that will raise the red flag
for you to say well hang on there's
another cost inflation and that's where
we
come full circle no this does not incr
create inflation because
inflation can be created when the
central bank and the banking system
create and inject money into the
non-bank economy and they do this for
unproductive purposes they do this too
much you get inflation or asset
inflation right
but this is not what happens here what
happens is a booking exercise within the
banking system the central bank and the
banks are together the banking system
and always saying is oh the central bank
is now going to use its powers to clean
up the balance sheets of the banks that
in itself doesn't inject any money into
the non-bank economy and therefore
cannot lead to inflation there's not a
single dollar this is injected into the
non-bank sector as a result of this and
that's what happened so bank credit
recovered after a year four five percent
six percent bank credit growth america
was the first country to recover after
2008 crisis
um and so you think it was the right
move
it was the right move if well i mean i
would have done it even better because
they should have imposed
certain rules we know when you bail out
the banks
you have a lot of power and they could
have used this to say okay from now on
we're going to do this properly they
didn't do that secondly they could have
um not favored the big banks so much
they really favored the big banks and
really you should have done this you
believe in socialism
no i don't but it's a crisis you see i
believe in the principle of moral hazard
that is who is responsible for this for
this crisis is the central bank they
should pay up and and end it it
shouldn't have happened in the first
place yeah but central banks is getting
money the more they put into it my
dollar goes lower so you're hurting me
no if you're doing that there's no
creating and you're delaying a time bomb
no
no you're getting rid of this as a
capitalist i'm a capitalist i'm a
full-blown capitalist i believe in
capitalism well then we must abolish
central banks and i would agree we don't
need central banks but now that we have
them and they're creating asset bubbles
yeah but you're feeding them
you're feeding the machine though you're
making it uh you're delaying the time
bomb for the next generation
see compared to japan and the u.s in
japan the central bank didn't do this so
then we had a 20-year recession all
these suicides you mentioned that's the
result of the central bank let me ask
you a question if you see because the
central bank power is increased when
they have boom busters i have a hard
time with this abolishes the boom bust
cycle can i push you back and you push
me back
it's pushed me back and what i'm saying
so okay so let's keep creating fake
success
so the current people of power don't
take a lot of hit
because god forbid the too big to fail
companies take a big hit let's protect
those guys and then you get the average
guy that's sitting there saying well you
you definitely believe in capitalism but
it's capitalism for the poor and
socialism for the rich right let's
protect the bigger and and
when a person gives me that argument i
sit down and i said you're partially
right because we keep doing this so so
okay so today let's go to today but i'm
not saying um you know what we should do
is uh
this is not success you know the central
banks have created the asset bubbles
they should then use the tools that they
have to quickly delete their mistakes
that's what i'm saying that's affected
me and my generation it's but it's not
you see if the center bank does it in
this way there's no money creation
there's no inflation in fact that's the
big difference to today 2020. so let me
come here there's a money creation where
does the money go to the bank if they're
going to buy a 20 stock rather than
pennies on a dollar they paid out a
hundred dollars
where do they get the money to give it
to the bank
there's no money injected as a result of
this bailout say the fed through it's
made in lane one two three you know
purchasing the non-performing assets of
the banks okay that in itself doesn't
inject a penny into the
non-bank economy because it's cleaning
up the banking sector it's an
intra-bank transaction you see in the
inside the banking system between the
fed and the banks therefore that in
itself doesn't create money and the
proof is in the pudding you know the
there was no inflation
as i as i was saying most people were
saying that oh the fed but that's not
proof in the pudding though i i i
disagree because just because there's no
inflation right off the bat the first
year second year that doesn't mean it is
not coming that doesn't mean winter is
coming all you did is you delayed winter
for 10 to 15 years okay and then severe
winter is coming then let me give you
two more examples please where this was
done and then i think you'll you get the
point that it is a limited measure for
emergency situations
but it doesn't actually create inflation
therefore once you are in the situation
you should do it but of course you
should also see why did the central
banks get us here in the first place and
avoid that so the two examples are
um
japan 1945
what was the state of the banking sector
well it was actually worse than in you
know
1989 1990 when the bubble burst it was
worse
in in 1990 the non-performing assets in
the bank system were 25
of the bank balance sheets which is a
lot
that is a lot it's anything more than 10
is enough to bankrupt the banks
but in 1945
the non-performing assets in the
japanese banking system were like 100
percent
because they had two types of assets
they had
um
greater east asian prosperity bonds war
bonds forced on the banks of a country
that just lost the second world war and
secondly
forced lending to the munitions industry
of munitions companies that were also
bust many now not even in japan anymore
because you know manchuria uh korea
taiwan are not part of japan anymore
after 45. so 100 non-performing assets
fine now the bank of japan decided okay
we've just been defeated devastated the
cities have been eradicated a lot of you
know incendiary bombs
um
flat earth here where there used to be a
city it's not a good moment to have a
banking crisis let's not have a banking
crisis they always have this option so
what are we going to do we will purchase
the non-performing assets from the banks
at face value it was actually a bit less
than face value but these are details
and that's what they did and so there
was so after the 1945 much bigger
banking crisis how long was the
recession how long was the period in
which banks did not lend to to
businesses anymore only one year
then they wrapped up lending the economy
recovered you're doing well in the 1990s
when the non-performing asset problem in
the banking system was much smaller
how long did it take 20 years why
because they still had their
non-performing assets the banks
continued to be risk-averse they reduced
they did not increase bank lending the
reason for the 20-year recession is very
simply look at bank credit to the
economy
negative for 20 years that's why there
was no recovery it's because they
constantly had these non-performing
assets this obstacle on their balance
sheet second example
august 1914
the united kingdom of great britain and
ireland declared war on germany austria
austria and hungarian empire and the
ottoman empire
the first world war had begun
now the city of london bankers came to
the government and the treasury and the
bank of england said oh by the way uh
we're bankrupt now
why what happened
well london already was the world's
financial center so all the paper
securities traded between germany
austria istanbul and so on was going
through london
a lot of it was going through london
they were holding what then was
considered irredeemable enemy paper and
it was too much value zero
because of the war they were bust what
did the bank of england do we just
declared war the first world war is
beginning um
let's not have a banking crisis so they
purchased the non-performing asset as
faith at face value
and by the way um you can actually even
make a profit um with standard
accounting out of this as well so what
i'm saying is that when you
when you are in such a bad situation
created by the central bank so we should
hold them to account why we're here
but then they do have a responsibility
to get us out of this
in the quickest possible way without a
long recession without suicides by
business people as we saw in japan
because of the recession because the
banks don't lend to them so more and
more firms go bust that can be avoided
and it is this obstacle called
non-performing assets on the bank
balance sheets and you can just take
them away at zero cost to the taxpayer
that i don't i okay so let me let me ask
you a question so
say the economy at the time where in
march of 2009 we put 1.25 trillion
dollars into the market quantitative
easing how much was in the market at
that time how much money was circulating
at that time
give me a number give or take whatever
let's make a number up
10 trillion
12 trillion i look at it on a flow basis
because credit creation is actually a
flow concept
um and whereas you know you're asking
about the stock of money but really the
question is how much new money is
created now that
in 2008 was was actually negative
because banks didn't create credit at
the end of 2008 and the central bank yes
put in trillions but in total that was
still less
than the shrinkage of the money doesn't
matter it doesn't matter all i'm asking
is i'm asking if if we had 10 trillion
and we put 1.25 trillion plus another
200 plus another 300 billion so add that
to
1.75 trillion and if we have a 10 10
trillion that's 17 and a half percent
my money devalued but it's not that it's
not what a hundred dollars became 83 you
have to understand the transaction i'm
saying is is a transaction
to shift assets from a to b inside the
banking system that does not create any
money in the economy it does not
increase the money supply at all
at all and that's why where did the
where did the money show up or where did
what are the two it doesn't show up
anywhere um because you're immediately
retiring it you you're putting it into
these non-performing assets it's the
central bank saying let's delete these
non-performance what's their money given
from central bank to banks
that's right was there money that oh yes
yes okay so where did that money that
the sale was
it was retired by writing off those
non-forming assets the central bank is
just right but that's still money though
the money went no it didn't it just
solved the bookkeeping problem what am i
missing here tom well you have to
understand that um i think what you need
excuse me i think the point we're
missing here and you need to help us and
when pat says to take the hat off the
complexity for the average person so
right now i have a toxic asset
i'm having to pay interest because
that's levered so that has a cost to me
i have correct i'm collecting from you a
payment on this trillion dollar asset
all of a sudden you can't make the
payment anymore well i've got a little
tiny payment over here that i was paying
to the central bank on the original
on the original
dollars so what you're saying is the
central bank knows that you're going to
stop paying me so now this is toxic or
non-performing asset right not
performing anymore just stuck so they'll
say i will take it off your balance
sheet so you no longer have to pay the
interest on the underlying capital and
i'll just take and own this a minute
later that doesn't show up on my balance
sheet and a minute later i don't have to
to make the cost payment and i'm not
getting
the revenue payment from you so
therefore it's off my balance sheet is
that what you're talking about yes
that's right okay so
for a consumer
help us understand this because we're
talking united states about student
loans
and you're the student and they're
saying well the students aren't going to
be able to pay these so [ __ ] let me
tell you why this is pissing me off
here's why i'm getting upset with this
i'm not agreeing i'm saying no i didn't
get that but let me tell you what what
what is happening so
the the the one and a half trillion
dollars of student debt that we have
right now whatever the numbers we got i
think it's a billion a trillion dollars
of credit card debt a trillion and a
half of student loan debt so i'm here
defending not to bail out student loan
debt right because you're weakening the
economy if you keep
bailing the average person out right i'm
defending not doing that because i'm
defending capitalism but at the same
freaking time at the top
you guys are doing deals to get in your
your your your your uh you're
essentially bailing out the freaking big
banks how the hell how how do you expect
people to not get pissed off because
and so now so now that's where i was
going we're about to go into the next
phase today
that
we we're sitting there oh it's okay oh
it's okay oh it's okay we keep printing
money oh it's okay oh it's okay the
government keeps getting bigger and
bigger and bigger it's okay don't worry
about it doesn't affect you don't worry
about it doesn't affect you and these
banks are doing buyback stocks and then
you're essentially
the people that are the small business
owners that are sitting there saying no
man go out there make your money you can
do it on your you can be a small
business owner
the market is not unfair the market is
not this and the average person sitting
there saying but pat do me dude i okay
fine i want to agree with you but at the
same time look at these suckers getting
bailed out yeah how about me the money
never flowed to me i remember during
that time real legitimate legitimate
small business owners in 0809 after
these guys got billed they're like okay
great money's going to flow out do you
know how difficult it was to get a 200
000 loan from chase chase was saying no
no no no no no no no no no no what do
you mean no
beckham no no no no you just got this
money to build people out so i i can see
how this
produces
the level of division
to get the average person to say here's
why i'm pissed off and by the way they
have a point
and and and the people that are trying
to do it the right way saying listen man
i don't have that kind of access to
capital so to say yeah don't worry about
it the money doesn't do anything it's
not what you think it is but is it being
printed yeah but it's not the way you
think it it's a distressed asset and
they're buying 20 at 100 bucks so you're
not really going to feel it i am going
to feel it there's two trillion dollars
no but it's not so so if people like you
who are the intellectuals that have gone
and done this research this is not my
world this is your role this is why we
have this is why i'm asking you the
questions you're not asking me the
questions right you're the expert i'm
the guy that's trying to learn from you
my concern is
then the market now is gonna have a
correction let me give you what i think
is going to happen and then give me your
argument on what's the right solution
now just before then just to point out
where we you know that we actually do
agree
um
because you see
the um
there were two problems with this
bailout in 2008 2009 by the fed and one
was that it was mainly the big banks
that were being bailed out and that is
unfair and that should be criticized and
that is
capitalism and also that's where cifi
came from um and you see but it it the
central bank did that because most
central banks actually have another
agenda which is not a good one and that
is to concentrate the banking system
and they use that to help the big guys
whereas the small banks they were not
helped and they had to merge and so in
the last 25 years 5000 banks have
disappeared in the us and 5 000 banks
have disappeared in the eurozone under
the ecb and that's the agenda they want
to have fewer and fewer and bigger and
bigger branches
that's not good we should found
constantly new small local community
banks which is something i'm doing
actually working on that
um we have to hold against this so that
is one problem of the way they did it
and i wouldn't have done it
that's the old rothschild bilderberg
argument right that they're going to
concentrate everything at the top am i
correct well
i'm just looking at the data and the
data says in the eurozone since the ecb
arrived five thousand banks have
disappeared and it's not the big ones it
is the small ones they're being forced
nugget but you know what i'm asking
about right there's a long-standing
there's a long-standing thing this is
world economic forum davos is that their
shadow organizations that date back to
the rothschilds and the bilderbergs
which is uh aimed toward ultimate
elimination of country boundaries and
consolidation of the banking system
under a single global parent actually
you can go back even further and you
read the communist manifesto by karl
marx
of 1800 and something and it says marx
came after this part right but it says
it says what they want is one
um one bank which is the central bank
and so get rid of all these banks
unfortunately that very much seems to be
the agenda at least of the ecb but the
second point i wanted to say where we
you know where we also very much agree
um is
the way it was done since 2020 has been
very different and even worse there we
have all the bad sides of this
intervention namely in 2020 what they
did is
um they forced the banks to increase
lending
at a time when bank credit was already
growing by six seven percent and the fed
expanded so we had massive massive money
creation in the economy and therefore
inflation and that's a big difference
2008 2009. so i was forecasting since
may 2020 we will get significant
can i can you ask your best and that
hurts the small guys in particular and
ordinary people
um yeah and i'm sorry to interrupt you
it's just sometimes it's hard to follow
you because you don't appear to breathe
right
take a breath between sentences so in
2020 and during covid we basically just
printed money and gave it to the common
man so what you're saying is what i'm
listening to is once upon a time value
of money was tied to gold gold had a
supply supply was finite and there was a
value on that gold so the value of the
finite gold supply determined the value
of the money or therefore the money
supply at the time over time gold became
property and asset bubbles associated
and the banks were actually lending
against that at some percentage right
and so the money supply would go
exponentially as banks were making
quotas and issuing loans so i can see
how there is also always an asset tie
and then all of a sudden we come to
covid and we print a whole bunch of
money in the united states we give it to
the common man you're saying that's
inflationary because it wasn't tied to
an asset and that in 2008 the problem
was that the mark to market on the asset
created an insolvent point for the bank
because now the asset
flipped am i correct well we don't need
the asset so in um in my analysis the
the asset here is not the key you know
money creation banks can always create
money and always could in the past even
in the gold standard i'm not declaring i
was following you i want to make sure i
understood
the question are you verifying what he's
saying i'm verifying what you're saying
because i'm asking a question the
question is therefore because the banks
are on quotas to make loans against
things and for businesses you said that
they said what's going on well you know
it's the uh the central banker right you
know fuki you know fukui you know it's
out there telling us we have a quote and
we have to make loans that you said was
not inflationary what was inflationary
was printing a bunch of money and giving
it to the common man
it was that's my question in japan it
was creating acid inflation which is bad
and and you know that
do you see my question pat i'm saying i
get it what i'm trying to so so for you
what you say what you're saying is
yeah quantitative easing is good if done
if i would have done it i would have
done it differently right okay so what's
the difference between that statement
you're making
versus the socialists and the communists
that say yeah i know everybody says
communism doesn't work and socialist
doesn't work
but if i would have done it i would have
done it differently no it doesn't work
quantitative easing doesn't work this
system doesn't work what they're doing
because again today
we're going to enter i know my
prediction is i've been in the financial
sector for 21 years now i got started
day before 9 11 with morgan stanley i'm
serious 7 6 31 26 life and health this
has been my world for the last 21 years
since i got out of the military okay
am i a ray dalio of course not am i a
economist no am i the guy that went to
mit or any of the universities oxford no
i don't have a four-year degree nor do i
have do i have a two-year degree i'm the
regular guy that's concerned and asks
questions who works his ass off and has
got big dreams and is curious that's
where i'm at so i know my prediction i
may be wrong
shit's about to hit the fan july 1st
it's officially going to be announced my
prediction is recession okay q3 it'll be
two quarters in a row it'll be announced
it's recession i don't think they can do
anything about it at this point they'll
announce recession july 7 july 14th but
in the first week or second week of july
they're gonna announce recession okay so
now they announced it so the powells of
the world and a janet yellens of the
world who are sitting here saying on
october 29th when she did this interview
with wolf blitzer i don't know if you've
seen this before if you can just play
the video i just want people to see the
20 seconds of it so she's supposed to be
the person who's the former fed chair
she's supposed to be the secretary of
treasury she's supposed to be the person
that we all trust and she's brilliant
and she's a genius and she's this
october 29 wolf blitzer rewind it a
little bit and pause it so they can hear
it on october 29th she says when she's
asked about inflation she downplays it
so watch this here for 30 seconds and
yesterday she says sorry tom
go back again because tom spoke so we
must go back a little bit clearly madam
secretary this inflation problem in the
u.s is not temporary right well i still
would say it's temporary although i
don't mean just a matter of a month or
two although monthly inflation rates are
substantial have substantially declined
um from where they were just four or
five years secretary to downplay this
information two days ago risk did that
contribute to the problems we're all
seeing right now
well um look i i think i was wrong then
about um you're who we hired inflation
um would take as i mentioned there have
been pauses
so okay so we go into recession say
first or second week of july
then they're gonna come out and they're
gonna say oh my god you know it's a show
recession and then they're gonna come
out with numbers and what we have to do
is powell's gonna come out with yelling
and biting and all these guys your
quantitative easing is well we have to
mix so then we go and print another
three trillion dollars for it it's not a
big deal no one's gonna see it so this
keeps getting delayed and delayed and
delayed and delayed
because
a guy like you whom i want to believe
you know this is not going to work long
term temporarily it could work but for
us to prevent inflation
i guess where i'm trying to get to is if
we leave it alone we don't do any
quantitative reasoning there's gonna be
many guys like you that are gonna say do
quantitative easing but i'm not saying
that but not saying but once you do in
fact i've said the opposite
in since may 2020 i've been warning they
are creating inflation they need to stop
they are creating inflation
idea 95 though yeah but it's for
different purposes it's when you have a
bust banking system after an acid bubble
and you've deflated and now bank credit
is shrinking in 2020 bank credit was
growing already already in february uh
january february by six percent you
don't need this qe the qe was the wrong
policy and i was very clear on that say
we don't do qv say we don't do qv say we
don't do any qv okay
we naturally let it said you said a
quote on your documentary that was uh
there's not a country who's changed its
social or economic system without a
crisis this is in your documentary which
i recommend everybody watching right
okay sounds good um
so okay i agree
i actually agree fully with that
statement
but i also think
that we've been extremely spoiled
it's like kids who all of a sudden get
into a rich family and they've been in
it for a while they don't know what hard
work is they don't know what's going on
and then daddy or mommy loses all the
money
and they have to go through the pain
and you can't just band-aid put a
band-aid on it right you kid listen son
we lost everything yes you have to go
get a job you have to go make money i no
longer have that hundred thousand
dollars that i'm paying you every year
as a allowance you no longer have that
kind of luxury that you've been living
for the last 15 years but dad what are
you talking about you know what am i
going to do my girl's going to leave me
she's going to leave you bro
and you're going to lose a lot of
friends you party but you get all the
tab at the bar you're right you're going
to lose that car of yours that you go on
a date with all the time that you look
hot you look good you ain't going to be
as cool as you've been the last 10 years
the coolest you've had the last 10 years
has been fake son son you're actually
not cool
you have to go earn the coolness is what
you got to earn america has millions of
people that have been cool the last 10
years that should not be cool
they need to lose it so for me
if we don't do nothing they're going to
propose another quantitative easing
they're going to propose it
if we do nothing
okay no quantitative easing
and we have to go through this
without anything being put into the
system from federal reserve without
anything being put in the system and
bailing out the next bank that's going
to be going down what happens if we do
nothing and how long will that last
well if already since 2020 they had done
nothing
it would have been much better
because what they created and these were
government decisions and central bank
decisions
is they on the one side restricted the
supply artificially which was
unnecessary and at the same time created
money and gave it into people's hands
and they the federal reserve forced the
banks to increase credit by purchasing
um assets from the non-bank sector so it
puts a lot of money into people's hands
so you restrict supply you increase
demand you create a lot of money you
will get inflation that was very clear
from may um 2020 onwards and i warned
about this and i said this is wrong and
unfortunately we are still on that path
um and it could now move towards
accelerating inflation we have a period
of um stagflation that's being created
artificially and that's the key thing
that means however we can at any time
end this and have proper policies and
the proper policies are when banks
mainly and and ideally only create
credit for productive purposes
and that is when banks small banks lend
to small businesses for business
investment increase
productivity implement new technologies
that should be increased and everything
else should be reduced if people want a
mortgage they should get it from a
non-bank lender and banks should not be
allowed to uh to invest in that so
that's how you you make sure only
existing money is used for asset
transactions you then you don't get
asset inflation
and you make sure small businesses have
enough money by helping the small local
community banks america has a lot of
those they need to be supported by the
central bank not the big banks now
actually we can compare now to to china
i think which is an interesting example
because there used to be you know
essentially stalinist type soviet union
type economy
in the 60s and then early 70s then in
1978 deng xiao deng xiaoping came to
power
and you know what he did what was the
biggest thing he did
that
created this success of the chinese
economy
he traveled to japan he went going to
these
evening these dinners um with the
japanese drinking a lot of sake and and
multi
and he got the truth out of them
about window guidance and that you can
use this window guidance tool for good
if you make sure banks
first of all that there's a lot of banks
a lot of small banks and the banks
create credit
mainly for business investment
and so when he came back and he rose to
power after 1978
in china what he did is he created a lot
of banks he started with this soviet
system of one bank monobank the central
bank
but then he created thousands of banks
small banks community banks savings
banks regional banks provisional banks
a few national champions as well but
now china has almost 5000 banks almost
as many as the us and that created these
40 years of double-digit economic growth
multiplying national income so and that
is very capitalist to have small local
banks
that generates a capitalist economy why
because
you see the money supply
creation process actually belongs to all
of us it's our privilege and if a
central institution is making these
decisions
that's never good it needs to be
decentralized and the best way is to
have small local banks you can watch
what they're doing you can attend their
meetings you can ask you can hold them
to account if they if they suddenly
support a strange project locals can
influence them right
you just flipped in 20 minutes you just
flipped because 20 minutes ago you said
what they did was right because the
money wasn't felt or seen in that
situation where we already have the
wrong system which is so centralized but
i'm against the centralized system
that's i'm telling you
i i see you cool you said this massive
government intervention rather than the
account rather the economist says that
the more relevant comparison is what
happened from march 2020 is much more it
came to certain uh
certainly centrally planned stalinist
soviet union types restrictions in what
scenarios what we have is massive
innovation by the government and the
economy by introducing restriction
including price controls on so many
parts of the economy as we've never seen
before in the uk right we're seeing that
also in the us well exactly and that's
what i'm criticizing i know you are but
but were you also saying what they did
with 2008 was the right move and you
said if you would have done it
differently you would have done it
slightly differently but you're still
supporting the central bank getting more
power but you see there's a sequence
they had created this acid bubble with
their centralized bad system and bad
policies
once you have created this it's like
you're falling over your bike should i
not help you so you don't crash yes i
help you quickly and you're saying oh
you should intervene and shouldn't help
me well look i know you can quickly
solve this problem but the bigger story
is we need to shift away from the
centralization that the central planners
love that's not good and we need to
decentralize and the best way to do this
is establish
local community banks yeah new small
banks then we get the centralized the
the decentralized system and that's what
made even china successful they moved
from the soviet system i would have only
i would have done it in a in a way of
uh uh
let all the
however many companies you got like i
remember when aig was going through aig
had a fleet of planes that they're
sitting on
aig owns planes yes go look it up aig
had a fleet of planes that the new ceos
like bob and moshe what are we doing
what business are we in and bob ben
moshe comes in and cleans house
and does what he does the 183 billion
and the 21 billion dollars of interest
he pays back within three to five or
seven years whatever the timeline was
but if some of these companies that are
bigger companies i'm sitting there
saying do you specialize in planes no
sell them do you specialize in this
knows what what is your core
competency what are you doing here's if
you want any kind of help i'm okay with
your hundreds big companies small
companies within a big company i'm okay
with you selling these to these other
people but you can't sit around doing
this because you don't know how to
operate companies i want more companies
than a few people that are controlling
the entire marketplace which is what
happens every time we bail out they end
up buying some of these other companies
and get more and more powerful so but
going back to it say we don't do
anything today
in u.s
40 the dollar has been printed whatever
the last two years right that they keep
talking about say we don't do nothing
how bad are things going to be and how
long would it last
well does that include
not uh to increase the the money supply
any further which would be good i mean
we should not increase it anymore zero
nothing else we vote on nothing we say
we're going through this
we're gonna buckle down and go through
this how long will it last and how ugly
will it be
it will depend on the strength of the
community banks the local banks and they
are quite strong in the u.s so i think
the u.s will
weather this
because small firms will still
receive backing
from their community banks
whereas in more centralized economies
where you also don't have these many
small local banks things would look much
worse
i think that is actually a good policy
at this stage of course we should have
done that already in 2020.
they took the wrong policies they
created too much money um for
unproductive purposes you know all my
work shows that that is wrong you should
only create money for productive
purposes and when i say create means
inject into the economy the bailout i
mentioned before doesn't inject new
money you see that's why under specific
circumstances it can help you have a
healthy banking system but it should
then also have the right incentives to
to land for productive purposes so say
say they don't do anything so let me go
back to my question in 2020 you said
they shouldn't have done it they
shouldn't have done lockdowns because if
you exactly force you to lock them then
you have to pay me so they should have
not done the lockdown so you don't have
to give the money because when you did
the lockdown you hurt the restaurants
but today say
we somehow democrats and republicans
both agree on one thing
i don't want any more bailouts
okay
and we drive the hell out of this
messaging we want no more bailouts to
these bigger companies we don't do
nothing
we're going to unite and we're going to
go through this time and these bigger
guys that have been spoiled for the
longest time and they've not been
working let them go through the pain to
see what we went through to come to the
top because you don't know what it is to
go through it right if we don't do
nothing
how ugly will it be how long will it
last so when i ask ugly here's what i'm
asking jimmy carter era you know the
interest rates where they hit right 16
17 18 it's pretty ugly what happened
during that time right and then reagan
came in and he did what he did why did
this happen i studied the 70s and most
people think oh it was an external shock
a supply shock even like today there was
a war and then energy price shock that's
the reason no it's not true
already
um
over one year before because oil prices
only started to rise from late 73 1973
but i can already see in the data of the
central banks and bank credit creation
gold standard a massive expansion from
1971 72
all of them and that's what created that
inflation they then were looking
desperately for a cover so that the
focus is not on them but they created
this inflation it was only sold and
marketed to people as oh it's the oil
price shock it's energy it's the middle
east blah blah it's not true it was the
central banks
that is a fact and
you know they should uh take
responsibility for that unfortunately
they're doing the same thing again now
so the inflation is again created by
then the question then becomes the
market policy so you say central banks
yes okay
but say we didn't do any creative
policies during that time
how long would have those high interest
rates lasted and how different would the
economy have been you see the high
interest rates what i showed with my
earlier study you know reconsidering
monetary policy is interest rates follow
growth and they follow nominal growth
so the the money creation was revved up
a lot in 1971
so one and a half two years later you
get nominal gdp rising and huge
inflation
and that's why interest rates had to go
up interest always follow growth that's
what's happening now it's all
predictable your concern is not interest
rates you're not worried about interest
rates it will be painful for people
clearly with mortgages that are you know
floating mortgages and so on and that's
something one should look at is policy
makers
but
in general just looking at the macro
economy and giving a quick answer it's
clear that
what's happening now is the result of
these bad decisions from 2020
we should
stop making bad decisions
doing nothing would be better that would
be a better policy than what they're
likely to do which is
create even more money and accelerate
the inflation which could be very
disastrous
so
it is time to change policy and but also
then to actually question this why do we
have such a system where these wrong
policies are taken
what can be done and
we should look at the strengths of the
us economy and one of the great
strengths is
that there's thousands of small local
banks we need to help them
and make sure that they won't be
squeezed out because the big guys want
to kill them that's what's happening in
europe of course and but they are what's
needed to make sure that your local
small firm will survive they need that
supply because even a tiny local
community bank will create money when it
lands that's like your own local money
creation it should be done for
productive purposes by giving it to a
business small firm that is doing
something productive then it's fair and
transparent how many meetings are being
had right now tom you think
with these big
bank guys that you know funded the
campaigns of different uh candidates
that are saying oh okay you don't want
to do anything oh okay no problem yeah
don't do anything see what we're going
to do when it comes on to re-election
time how much you think the policymakers
are afraid of not bailing out the bigger
guys because the bigger guys have bottom
through campaign support and different
kinds of things or do you think that
does not play a role i think candidates
are scared to death of big banks i think
both sides they all are scared to death
yeah to patrick's question can you
follow up one part that you haven't
addressed yet so he was saying how bad
could it be how do we get out how long
will it last can you go to how long will
it last because you've said how bad
could it be it could be reasonably bad
on interest rates and the average guy
with the mortgage and then how do you
get out we need strong local community
banks helping local businesses that
helps job creation local growth local
economy
taking the pain off the people who just
got hit with their credit card interest
and their mortgage interest right main
street as we call it how long do you
think this will take that was the third
part of pat's question i'd love to your
take on that yes well
if the scenario is that we we are not
increasing the the money supply further
for the big guys
and we we don't have this inflationary
policy anymore
then it's just going to be one one and a
half years for the previous money
creation to feed through and then stop
and then inflation will stop
because inflation needs constant
expansion in money creation and you'd
think this is so obvious that when you
have inflation they would actually stop
the money creation but the history shows
no they keep going and they keep
creating more money sadly but we're
talking about the scenario where you do
nothing and you don't increase the money
supply well then also the inflation
would stop after one and a half years
okay so you're saying if i this is just
a clarification that
okay guys it'll take about a year and a
half let your strong local bank support
local economies that 1.4 trillion was
like food poisoning and you got to get
it through the body you got to go throw
it you go to the bathroom you got to get
it through it but once it's through
largely
all these things are returned to nominal
and inflation on things everything from
milk to gasoline which hurts the average
person is going to moderate is that what
you're saying it's about that's right a
year and a half that's right and
historically speaking pat what's very
interesting if you look back even the
great recessions
not depressions but great recessions
have usually only been about 18 months
and so you're saying that historical
norms that the peak impact of the
recession because remember there's a lot
that happens into it but when we all
admit yeah crap it's a recession 18
months that's what you're saying 18
months yes yeah okay
that is the lead time that's also why in
2020 i was forecasting significant
inflation to hit us one and a half years
later which is you know which has been
this year
it also goes with the thought that says
all sessions are three years
from the moment you know something's
happening and you don't admit it
politically pat you know like you know
milk is going up gas is going up but you
don't admit it no it'll be like janet
yellen a year and a half ago just
speaking to tv oh yeah maybe a month or
so two months
so from that moment to when we really
see growth again is a 36 month cycle and
what we really have in the united states
is we have a year of denial by the
political
folks that are that are speaking to
voters so there's a year of denial then
there's 18 months of oh my god this is
real
and then
we have evidence of growth yeah and of
course the problem has been lack of
accountability you know if you take
wrong which is the year of there is
accountability at the voting booth which
is why you start with a year of denial
but not by this you know there's no
accountability of the central planners
the ecb has been saying oh there's no
inflation it's transitory you know
they're all speaking the same reading of
the same script well they need to be
held accountable
um you know they all all the top layer
needs to go because they sure when's the
last time you watch your own documentary
princess of the end the whole one well
i've watched bits and pieces because
people make me aware of this part in
that part but the whole one that that
goes a few years back you haven't
watched it yet the whole watch is not
the finish how many years how many years
has it been
the whole one well maybe i don't know
three years or something who owns that
documentary
it's um
i think it's open source oh it's open
source it's yeah you can see it on on
youtube but but so there's nobody that
owns owns that wasn't a media
it was done by
two guys um
[Music]
um what are they called something with
politely you'll still see it it does
mention it you know michael hovert and
michael oswald
are these guys
you're in contact with or no yes okay
i'd be interested in buying the
documentary if they would like to speak
i'd like to
speak to you about buying a documentary
because
i i think
it
reveals a lot of what's going on in
america today i thought it was very well
done and i think people
uh are are were a little bit oblivious
the last few years and we've been too
overly confident about how much money
has been made thinking we are that smart
and we're that you know brilliant of
money makers but uh
i think i think the pruning process is
coming
i think some people are going to be
exposed the next 18 to 24 months
and i wouldn't mind some of these bigger
guys that keep getting billed out and i
wouldn't mind it being some of them
to go through it because
it is unfair for the guys that are
trying to do it the right way who are
constantly being categorized in the same
level of these other bankers that get
bailed out and these small businesses
that are doing the work because when
crisis comes
the founder the ceo and the c suites
during the next 18 to 24 months if you
thought you were working a lot the last
three years you were not working the
last three years matter of fact i'm
willing to bet that most people
had the least hardest working season the
last two to three years okay most people
because it's been as hard as it may
sound oh my god it was so hard we've not
really worked that hard we've actually
gotten lazier if we were to look at it
again i may be wrong no i'm with you 100
but i think the next two years because
you heard what elon musk said yesterday
elon musk said look
um
if you're going to pretend that you're
working 40 hours from home come pretend
at the office that you're working from
home and if you're not coming to the
office anymore you're fired go to
another company right
that process is coming
very soon and we're gonna know who was
actually working the last two years and
who wasn't this is an email that we send
out right i don't know did you see the
email he sent that or no
i saw a comment on it so yeah yeah he
says anyone go pretend somewhere else
no here it is he says anyone who wishes
to do remote work must be in the office
for a minimum
of 40 hours per week or depart tesla
parentheses and i mean minimum yeah this
is less than we ask of factory workers
okay so meaning if the front line guys
are working out art you ought to as well
if there are particularly exceptional
contrib contributors for whom this is
impossible i will review and approve
those exceptions directly moreover the
office must be a main tesla office not a
remote branch office unrelated to job
duties for example being responsible for
fremont
uh factory human relations but having
your office to be in another state so i
think the next two years uh people gonna
be actually working okay the last couple
years we haven't been working folks if
you're listening to this
if you claim you're a worker and if
you're not a worker you're going to pay
price next two years but if you are a
worker the market's going to definitely
recognize you the next couple years
because winter is coming sometimes we
have to be able to sit down and have
serious conversations with our family
with our friends with our peers with our
kids with our business partners to say
okay guys
buckle down you know we're gonna see
what these guys gonna be doing the
reality of it is uh we're not presidents
we're not governors we're not you know
policymakers we got to kind of do what
we're doing right now and hopefully
we'll get through the season together
uh but appreciate you for coming out i
thought this was great i want you to
know i'm truly interested in that
documentary so if you do speak to the
two guys i'd love to have that
conversation with them if i can just uh
say a few more things some of things you
raised which i haven't um
responded to gold um
i like gold i think it's it's a good
hedge against inflation it's i think the
price is totally artificially suppressed
central banks are the biggest owners of
gold and there's a lot of
ways paper gold you can manipulate the
price and i think what we're seeing is
simply
it's artificially low which in a way is
a great opportunity you know people have
been slow they can still get into gold
uh crypto well i think that's part of
the um at least was part of the the
central planners goals to establish
central bank digital currencies which we
also should uh
work against because that's going to be
very dangerous it's a control tool not a
currency and so you're against digital
currencies you're getting well again
ethereum against central bank digital
currencies
i'm very much called decentralization
and if people want a decentralized
system they want to start their own i'm
all for it so i'm actually backing a
valhalla network uh ollie start heading
it one of my associates and we're
setting up
a system of decentralized autonomous
organization and and um where people can
vote and also we're using this to set up
community banks
so everything needs to be decentralized
we need to
um hold against this current very strong
pressure by the central planets they're
using all these crises
to centralize everything and that is
really bad
that is you know that is communism what
we're seeing is increased
sovietization of of you know one thing
after another we have to hold against
that and i think decentralized
decentralization is the key setting up
local community banks
uh we're doing this with a valhalla
network as well so in that sense i like
uh you know cryptocurrencies when
they're decentralized and that's a key
uh part of their of their strategy
we'll see uh uh what's gonna happen
there i'm just i'm just curious when
this recession hits and we go through
the next six twelve eighteen months
uh i'm i'm so watching all the triggers
to see how crypto's gonna respond how
gold's gonna respond is gold actually
gonna have its vertical move here where
they're gonna go to 253
i think gold is cheap right now if you
ask me yeah same as me you agree with
that i highly agree i think gold is
cheap right now and
i think if the crypto community stays
strong and they vote more people into
office
uh whether it's congress senate governor
whatever it is they get more pro crypto
people that go into office i think
they'll be able to
hold off long term but if we go through
the central bank federal reserve bailing
out all these other guys
uh i hope that doesn't happen but i feel
a messaging coming that we have to do
this or else
in the next two three four five six
months i don't know i hope i'm wrong but
anyways uh uh we're gonna put the link
below to the documentary we're gonna put
the link below for your book and how to
find you a couple of those papers that
he mentioned if you can put that in the
description as well i think you
mentioned four or five papers for those
that want to read it just
put it doesn't need to be in the chat
box but put in the description that
people can find uh uh tyler taylor uh
tyler came up with the idea of us uh
introducing membership him and mario
talked about it and we just launched it
because many of you guys were asking
about it so now we're doing that if you
saw a few people that
became members here today uh tyler can
you take a quick moment i mean i can
recognize some of the names
we have underwood we have yiemi mourinho
we have doug few other people that
became members of the pbd podcast can
you share with them the benefits and
what this is going to look like what
access they have what different things
we'll be doing with this yes so it's i
mean it's just a really good way for us
to give back to the people that support
the podcast the most like everybody that
tunes in every day watches etc there you
know there are certain things that you
can get through youtube memberships that
you just can't get anywhere else like
custom badges
denoting how long you've been a member
custom emojis we're doing members only
polls members only call into the show
access to a private youtube community
that we're gonna set up you know only
members can be a part of uh members-only
questions like we're really trying to
give back to these guys we're even gonna
try to set up
a monthly webinar with you
uh just for people that are subscribed
to the youtube membership so like we're
really trying to and is it one that we
can communicate they'll be able to ask
me questions absolutely that's gonna be
it's gonna be a monthly zoom with you
they can ask questions they can send in
their questions you'll spend time with
them they'll get to be on a call with
you yeah once a month you know it's it's
really we're really trying to give back
to people that we we know who supports
the channel and is always here and
always watching and we want to do
something special for them why i love it
so how do they find out more about it is
there a link to press is there something
to do or no yep so we're gonna put a
link in the description uh anytime they
go to the channel there's a button that
says join if you click the button that
says join you'll see we have a few
different tiers offered um and we'll
make sure that this is everywhere it's
easy to access easily i'd love to and
we'll get back to you guys appreciate
you it's not is that mine or is that
yours because it's not mine okay
appreciate you and folks you know as you
guys go through this uh journey with
myself and and and us here vitamin pd
podcast i'm simply a regular guy that's
curious and wants to learn and i ask the
questions and i want to know what the
hell is going on so if you're somebody
that's also curious and sometimes maybe
i'm asking a question that you're
thinking about we appreciate your
support and sometimes i may ask a
question that you're not thinking about
or i might ask a question make a comment
that you don't agree with but
this isn't uh this this podcast isn't
created for us to agree this podcast is
created for us to be able to have
discourse uh yesterday a guy sent me a
message on twitter uh uh saying you
[ __ ] you know i can't believe
you're saying this about guns you know
did i share that with you or no
yeah and then he says and i i respond
back to him
you're [ __ ] [ __ ] i said your
approach is why we can't make progress
give me your solution to the problem on
guns and try your best not to insult
well your sarcasm on twitter involves
comparing cars made to transport to guns
made to kill i'm stooping to your level
i said take a deep breath and try giving
solutions we're not enemies kids so then
he says ban on automatic weapons no
civilian needs
and he gives all this stuff it's great
how about adding training thanks for
sharing your ideas it gives me insight
on how you would approach a complex
issue did you watch the video and
anyways we finished it off on good note
and we're laughing and talking to each
other right but
purpose of this podcast is for discourse
and many times i'll be wrong many times
we'll challenge the guests like we did
today and many times we'll be right and
many times the guests will be right but
regardless we will all leave hopefully
thinking saying huh that was an
interesting conversation that i was a
part of earlier today on the podcast so
hopefully you enjoyed the podcast as
much as i did and uh if you did give us
a thumbs up and subscribe to the channel
and follow our yesterday richard werner
once again thank you for coming out and
being a guest on a podcast this was
great thanks for having me i enjoyed it
thanks very much take care everybody
saturday we have a special podcast that
we're doing with nikki fried if you
don't know who she is you may want to
join us
thank you everybody have a great weekend
bye bye bye
you